there is
nothing better than staying at home and
crafting with your kids
and that's why i'm so excited that we
are here
working with michaels they have a free
online arts and crafts program
called camp creatology for kids of
all ages you pick a class you sign up
you check out the supply list and you
can also buy the coordinating class
bundle and
you're ready to craft all right now
joining me
to craft today is layla height
whose dad is actually our show's
director hi laila
hi today we are going to make the yarn
woven
butterfly we're going to take our two
sticks and we're going to lay them on
top of each other and then we're going
to take the yarn
and we are going to place it until it's
covered what color is you using
um i'm using pink and blue all right
take the middle and we want to leave a
little string out
we're going to use it to tie it in a
knot and then just start wrapping around
what it should look like is the body of
your butterfly
now step two we want to use a different
yarn to wrap each side
and then we're gonna tie it a knot and
repeat it on the opposite side so then
we're gonna
secure it around the x because if we're
only wrapping it like this you could
pull it off
step three we want to get a pipe cleaner
and we want to bend the pipe cleaner
and we want to lay it in the middle now
you can take your pipe cleaner
wrap it around and then secure it with
beads
then you can bend the pipe cleaner
and you can create the little butterfly
antennas
i might even stick the ends of my pipe
cleaner back inside the
bead securing it yeah oh
great minds thinking alike i love mine
that looks gorgeous
the way we make it in our individual
ways
is what makes it beautiful step four is
the tada wow factor
butterfly cheers cheers well
thank you leila and thank you to camp
creatology
this is running july 12th through august
6th
and you go to michaels.com forward slash
camp creatology to register and join in
on the fun
of making it the only way you can make
[Music]
it
[Music]
you